okay now in language learning i always
say you've kind of got to do the bits
and pieces and the big picture the big
picture for me is listening and reading
doing things that I'm interested in so
i'm listening to my polish history i'm
reading polish history creating links at
link but you also have to do the nuts
and bolts and i'm getting ready not when
i start speaking so for that I use my
iPad and I give it a bit of a
demonstration here and won't show you in
a while but because i'm using puters
stories and in each story there's a
bunch of questions now i try to answer
the questions to prepare myself for
Speaking so here's a question sylvie
bully drew okay that's a statement then
comes a question cheat sylvie balaclava
yeah seven yeah bali guava bali boo boo
yah yah yah bali guava okay that's the
answer so your body your body broo broo
sylvie buddy brew so because i have the
sentence view here on my ipad i see each
question and then coco coco bully proof
the answer is Sylvie Sylvie believe you
Sylvia Young bali zoo ok that's the
answer drew polygon use odd go genie ok
that's the statement so then okay d
Sylvie bali drew Sylvie bali drew wolf
gajini audio genie Sylvie bali truck or
go jeanette next so nobly yo odio
jeanette the answer is broo broo bali yo
or go Gina and if you come and have a
look here they can see how they the
sentences move so I'm in sentence mode
here drew bush group bolio odd go Gina
so cheesy vjooq Bali odd Dragic minute
yeah
sylvie a brute bully or go Jeanette Nene
advance at minute you're believe douche
or go Jinny so Coco beautifully so
here's this process it's basically
simple stories simple questions the what
I think is very clever is that puter
gives you the sentence you have to think
back to the story the sentence is given
to you right there and you have to try
to say out loud the answer so I've just
started actually answering these
questions out loud so I'm not very good
at it but if I continue doing this for a
few weeks in combination with my
listening and reading where I'm
acquiring a lot of vocabulary I think
I'll be ready to start speaking the
beginning of november so there you have
it thank you for listening bye for now